ultimately when it is all said and done
it will not be what you own or how much
money you are worth that matters what
will truly matter is what you have done
to earn what you own
the lines often blur between what we
have done on what we own because what we
own is a tangible way to distinguish and
believe that what we have done has value
if I do something and receive a certain
amount of money for it then it is fair
to assume that what I did had value
equal to the money I receive for it but
this method of determining real value in
life is not always accurate although it
may be true that what I did has monetary
value it is not necessarily true that
what I did had any personal value and it
is just as important if not more so to
have personal interest in the things we
do in order to claim any real value in
them it is very possible to own lots of
things and have lots of money but still
do very little in terms of creating
pride value and contribution in life and
that is a very important distinction we
must make
we live in a time where there is massive
opportunity to find creative value
interest and fulfillment in what we do
for work simultaneously we also live in
a time where making money in meaningless
roundabout ways is easier than ever
people are selling ebooks on how to
write and sell ebooks people are selling
webinars on how to make and sell
webinars people are making YouTube
channels not for the love of video
creation but for the sole purpose of
making money at any cost of quality and
authenticity this is not to single out
those who participate in any of these
areas there are and have previously been
endless ways in which people make money
only for the sake of making money void
of personal interest or fulfillment in
what they do
anyone who works for a company that they
do not care about in a position that
they do not like and anyone who chooses
to do things or follow career paths that
sacrifice their values interests and
passions solely out of the desire and
desperation for wealth are all examples
of feeble self-sacrifice surely life
requires sacrifice but when it comes to
making money what is the right amount of
sacrifice is it more important to make
larger sums of money or is it more
important to maintain integrity and
authenticity it is clear that there must
be a balance but when we determine this
balance for ourselves we must remember
that what matters most in life is what
we do not what we own the only things
that will make us truly feel alive are
our experiences how honest we can remain
to ourselves and those we care about and
how much we can contribute to what we
believe in and enjoy of course we need
to make money in order to do these
things but we must ask ourselves how
much money is enough money and how much
self is enough self whatever balance it
takes to ensure that you will be able to
look back and appreciate the depth of
your connection to life and know that
you never shortchange yourself is the
balance you must create
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder